-BTS has been
on the show all week,
and we love having them.
Thank you for being on our show.
But since they can't actually
be here in person,
we thought it would be fun
to challenge them to a new game.
This is the Zoom Olympics.
Check it out.
-♪ Zoom Olympics,
Z-Z-Z-Z-Zoom Olympics ♪
♪ Zoom Olympics,
Z-Z-Z-Z-Zoom Olympics, Zoom ♪
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Bell dinging ]
-Jimin wins!
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
-Go, go, go, go!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Bell dinging ]
-Jung Kook wins!
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my gosh.
♪♪
[ Bell dinging ]
-Whoa! Whoa! Stop, stop!
My gosh.
♪♪
-Jin wins!
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Bell dinging ]
-Oh, my gosh!
-RM wins!
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
-All right. Here we go.
13 seconds.
We have 10 seconds.
♪♪
Oh, my gosh.
Jimin, hurry up!
♪♪
[ Dinging ]
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-Jimin, you're such a cheater.
-Jung Kook wins!
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
-Here we go. Don't --
-Easy. Easy.
♪♪
Ooh. Ooh. Yes. Keep going.
You have 4 seconds!
3 seconds! 2! 1 second! Go!
[ Dinging ]
-RM is the winner!
-RM wins!
[ Beeping ]
-Go!
-Whoa!
[ Indistinct shouting ]
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-This is great, man.
2 seconds! Hurry up!
-[ Dinging ]
-All right. That's it.
Time-out. Time-out.
Stop shaking. No more shaking.
Let's count up
how many each player got.
-J.K.
One, two, three, four.
-49. 49.
-49?
-RM has 47!
-47! Whoa!
-Winner!
-Oh, by two picks?
[ Dinging ]
The winner is...
Jung Kook!
-Jung Kook is the champion!
-My thanks to BTS. Stick around.
We got more "Tonight Show,"
everybody. Come on back.